CONGRESSIONAL WATCH.
WE'RE JOINED BY NEWS SENATOR,
MARSHA BLACKBURN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU WON BY A BIG MARGIN IN THE
END.
THERE WERE POLL THAT IS HAD YOUR
RACE CLOSE.
YOU RAN AWAY WITH T. WE'RE VERY
HAPPY WE SUPPORTED YOUR
CANDIDACY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHERE IS THE SENATE ON THIS
WHERE A LOT OF THE INSANITY IN
THE HOUSE, OF NANCY PELOSI AND
SOME OF THESE MORE RADICAL
MEMBERS, IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
SO WHERE IS THE SENATE
SPECIFICALLY ON STANDING UP FOR
SECURED BORDERS FOR THE COUNTRY?
>> I THINK LEADER MCCONNELL HAS
SAID IT WELL.
IT HAS TO, WHATEVER COMES TO THE
SENATE, HAS TO INCLUDE BORDER
FUNDING, AND REASON FOR THAT,
SEAN, IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT IS ASKING FOR
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF 1
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF P
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF R
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF E
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF T
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF O
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF F
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF T
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF E
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF B
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF D
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF E
$5 BILLION, THAT IS 1-TENTH OF .
WE ARE REQUIRED TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY AND PROVIDE FOR THE UPON
COMMON DEFENSE.
THIS IS THE PART OF PROTECTING
THAT SOVEREIGNTY IS THE PART OF
PROTECTING THE COUNTRY, AND IT
IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
COMING TO THE TABLE.
THEY'RE REFUSING TO NORTH.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO MAKE A DEAL
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
IF I WERE SOMEONE WITH A DREAMER
IN MY FAMILY, I WOULD BE VERY
UPSET WITH THE DEMOCRATS RIGHT
NOW, BECAUSE THAT PATH TO
LEGALIZATION THAT THEY HAVE
OFTEN SAID IS WHAT THEY WANT,
THAT IS SOMETHING ON THE TABLE
AND YOU ARE HEARING NANCY PELOSI
SAYING NOT ONE DOLLAR, NOT ANY
MONEY.
>> NO, TO BE FAIR, SHE OFFERED A
DOLLAR.
>> OH.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SHE DID.
SHE OVERRED A DOLLAR.
>> WE HAVE HAD MANY PEOPLE
MURDER BY THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AND AS A SHERIFF IN THIS PROGRAM
THAT MENTIONED, HE BELIEVES THAT
OFFICERS THINK WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM BECAUSE THE PERSON
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT MURDER
WAS IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, OUTSIDE OF BEING IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
HAD I.C.E. BEEN A LOUD DO THEIR
JOB, THEY WOULD HAVE DEPORTED
THIS INDIVIDUAL.
AT WHAT POINT WHEN DRUGS POUR
INTO THE COUNTRY, AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND GANG MEMBERS AND
POTENTIAL TERRORISTS  AND THOSE
WHO COMMIT VIOLENT CRIMES WHEN,
YOU DON'T STOP THEM AND YOU HAVE
CITIES AND STATES AIDING  AND
ABETTING THEM BY NOT TURNING
THEM OVER TO I.C.E., DO THEY
BEAR RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
FUTURE ACTIONS OF THOSE
CRIMINALS?
>> WELL, YES, AND WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IS THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS OPEN BORDER, YOU HAVE EVERY
TOWN, A BORDER TOWN AND EVERY
STATE, A BORDER STATE.
AND THESE GANG ANDS DRUG
TRAFFICKERS, HUMAN TRAFFICKERS,
SEX TRAFFICKERS ARE COMING TO A
COMMUNITY NEAR YOU.
THEY ARE ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY,
AND PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOWS THAT.
THIS IS WHY YOU HAVE OUR BORDER
PATROL AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SAYING, SECURE THAT BORDER, WE
NEED A WALL WE NEED TO HAVE A
BEARER BECAUSE THAT WILL HELP
KEEP PEOPLE FROM COMING IN.
IT WILL SERVE AS A WAY TO STOP
THE TRAFFICKERS WHEN YOU TALK TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
CHILDREN, OR THEIR SPOUSES OR
LOVED ONES TO THESE ILLEGAL
ALIENS, MANY OF THEM CRIMINAL,
ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DEPORTED.
IT IS HEART BREAKING AND
TENNESSEANS, WANT TO SEAT BORDER
SECURED.
>> L I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU, AT
SOME POINT, THEY BEAR SOME OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY BY NOT
ENFORCING THE LAWS.
SENATOR.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK IN YOUR